your mom said you thinking about bailing
on school I'm not bailing on it it's
already accepted for the Fall that's
fine singers on the Russian in the fall
theater you feisty
I am yeah that's awesome so what's up
with Russia anybody come out yeah of
course yeah we actually got a party on
Saturday
this is Phi Mu or gentlemen
exciton beside you here cuz these are
some of the best days I've known you're
gonna be fly sick we're gonna do stuff
with their lives well they're not gonna
let you in here my brother do you need
to be here welcome to hell we go sir our
initiation is a rite of passage take it
take it thank you
who was first president George
Washington sir wrong drink who shot John
F Kennedy I'm wrong drink one
condo-style there we go look I would do
this myself all right they just do this
to weed out the weak ones this pledge
getting weirder pledges got to go
through hell otherwise what's the point
maybe she just quit dude if you clip
there's another guy that couldn't hack
it
I'm having sex for the first time in my
life one it's stupid but it's not
because I mean none of it matters at all
these matters to me look we haven't been
doing anything every other fraternity on
campus hasn't been doing I'm curious and
the one who said you are my special girl